dax da silva quitte la direction de
lightspeed l'entreprise qu'il a fondée
il cède son poste à jean paul chauvet
litespeed vend des logiciels de paiement
numérique partout dans le monde à plus
de 150000 restaurants et autres types de
détaillants l'action a perdu plus de 70%
de sa valeur depuis qu'un vendeur à
découvert accusées litespeed de
surévaluer l'entreprise c'était en
septembre dernier avec nous ce soir le
nouveau pdg de lightspeed jean paul
chauvet bonsoir bonsoir monsieur fillion
le chauve est pourquoi dax da silva
quitte la direction de l'entreprise
il quitte pas la direction de
l'entreprise il va être que maintenant
chairman du board bombay dax il prend
travaillent ensemble depuis depuis plus
d'une dizaine d'années maintenant et en
fait toute la stratégie de la compagnie
a été bâtie entre lui et moi et en fait
la réalité c'est que tous les tous les
ans on doit se réinventer en doivent en
vue que la compagne est en très forte
croissance et en fait on pensait que le
moment était maintenant et que le moment
était venu pour que maintenant je prenne
les rênes ça fait plusieurs années que
mon qu'en fait j'ai temps mais elle au
sein de lightspeed que j'ai aussi la
responsabilité des produits et donc ont
pensé que c'était le bon moment la
dernière chose c'est que si on vient
d'embaucher un certain nombre de
nouveaux ports member et dax qui connaît
très bien la stratégie en interne on
trouvait que c'était aussi un très bon
moment pour que lui puisse aligner le
board complètement avec la vision de que
nous avons en interne et s'assurer que
finalement tout le monde est aligné en
verre créer de la valeur pour les
clients et comme on est en forte
croissance où vous l'avez peut-être vu
mais aujourd'hui on sait nos résultats
et que nos résultats étaient très bons
on trouvait que c'était le bon moment
vous avez annoncé une perte nette à
votre dernier trimestre dans vos
résultats financiers et à quand la
profitabilité parce qu'on voit
effectivement qu'il y a des éléments de
croissance pour litespeed mais à quand
la profitabilité pour litespeed
donc pour qu'on ait la profitabilité l
état de niveaux première première chose
la profitabilité on a aujourd'hui à peu
près 300 mille clients dans un marché de
millions et de millions donc en fait on
nous ce qui est important quand on parle
de profitabilité c'est de regarder le
la profitabilité unitaire c'est à dire
quel est le coût d'acquérir le client
versus quelle est la valeur nos clients
et sur ce point de vue si vous regardez
un client qui prend litespeed et qui
prend les paiements la valeur du client
et cette fois le ce que ça nous coûte de
l'attirer donc c'est à dire que notre
compagnie au niveau unitaire est
extrêmement rentable maintenance qui se
passe c'est qu'aujourd'hui on à 3000
employés on est on est sans doute le
numéro un dans notre dans notre domaine
est en fait ce qui se passe c'est que
comme nous continuons à croître à une
vitesse très forte à un moment ou un
autre la profitabilité va être là donc
si vous regarder à travers les derniers
quarts et moi ça fait douze cars cancon
et public on a toujours été au delà des
attentes si vous regardez dans les
derniers quarts les dernières années
notre objectif c'est de faire en sorte
que la perte en pourcentage du chiffre
d'affaires se réduit hélas car si encore
une fois on était au delà des attentes
en termes de pertes si vous regardez la
période ajusté ebit on était à 7
millions versus inattendu marché de 8 à
9 mai dans l'objectif d'arriver à un
profit je présume tout à fait trimestre
oui notre objectif c'est d'arriver à
profitabilité dans les années qui
viennent ok le kilo prochain on va on
devra beaucoup plus de clarté sur quand
est ce qu'on va justement la wii faire
le croisement perte est parfait on
surveillera donc les résultats du
prochain trimestre en septembre dernier
le vendeur à découvert ce blues pointent
a dit que votre titre était surévalué
vous a accusé de cacher de l'information
et l'action depuis ce temps la chute est
quand même perdu 70% de sa valeur il ya
un recours collectif également qui est
en cours et qui représentent les
actionnaires qui ont acheté les titres
de lightspeed entre le 11 septembre 2020
et le 3 novembre 2021 qu'est ce que vous
allez faire monsieur chauvet pour
rétablir la confiance des investisseurs
envers votre entreprise
oui bon donc premièrement
la réalité de ce cloud print et de
s'exécute août les allégations sont 100%
pause on a été très clair et on l'a dit
maintenant la réalité de ces compagnies
là ce qu'elle bénéficie finalement d'une
perte de l'action donc elles ont
tendance à vraiment essayer de trouver
des sujets qui vont faire en sorte qu'on
on va être très mal représentés dans le
cadre là explique peux pas parler pour
les autres on a été très clair et en
fait on a même fait des audits internes
après avec le porte avec des compagnies
externe 100% des allégations sont
fausses on est une compagnie très
transparente en est une compagnie en
très forte croissance et donc pour nous
écouter tout ce que je peux vous dire
c'est que la technologie ou les
compagnies antec de manière générale se
porte pas très bien depuis quelque temps
et c'est sûr que ce rapport a pas aidés
mais encore une fois aujourd'hui on est
sorti le résultat auquel est ce qu'il ya
un lien monsieur sauver le départ de
monsieur da silva ou en tout cas le
changement là la direction est ce qu'il
ya un lien avec cet enjeu qui s'est
passé avec ce pôle pointe
donc le le changement avec tact ça fait
des années qu'on parle de ça bien avant
tout tout ce qui s'est passé en début
d'année donc de l'année fiscale dernière
c'était déjà le sujet donc pour pour
nous on ne gère pas notre compagnie en
fonction de ce que disent les sources
externes on gère notre compagnie en
fonction de ce qui doit être fait au bon
moment donc encore une fois d'accès mois
on n'a pensé qu'à ce moment c'est le bon
moment c'est moi qui a géré toutes les
acquisitions pour litespeed c'est moi
qui étais très opérationnellement le
leader depuis depuis un certain temps
dans la compagnie donc on a voulu juste
s'assurer que maintenant dax au niveau
du bord puisse aussi orienter le board
aller dans la direction qui nous
intéresse c'est à dire de continuer à
faire de la forte croissance tout en
ayant un objectif très clair au niveau
de la profitabilité très bien monsieur
chauve et on va continuer de suivre avec
intérêt litespeed merci merci beaucoup
bonne soirée
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne ici et redit
oh